president biden postponed a planned trip
to michigan today because of the weather
his team back in washington continues to
work on a major immigration policy
overhaul
but there are serious concerns about
whether the bill would get enough
support
to get through the senate white house
correspondent kristen fisher has details
tonight
congressional democrats unveiled
president joe biden's sweeping
immigration reform bill
by opening with the question that
matters most does this bill have
any chance of passing the senate with 60
votes
and the answer is we won't know until
we try all of the president's recent
predecessors republicans and democrats
have tried but failed to pass
comprehensive immigration reform
addictions run deep in this capital when
it comes to immigration
lord knows we need to reform our
immigration system to every citizen call
congress and tell them to finally
after all of these decades secure our
border
but their failures haven't stopped
president biden from trying again
at the center of his u.s citizen act of
2021
is an eight-year pathway to citizenship
for 11 million undocumented immigrants
the bill would also raise the current
per-country caps for visas
and replace the term alien in federal
immigration laws
with non-citizen so house minority
leader kevin mccarthy tweeted today
democrats have a plan to open america's
borders but not america's schools
tells you everything you need to know
but president biden and congressional
democrats
are already signaling that while they're
pushing ahead on immigration reform
they're also open to a more piecemeal
approach with smaller stand-alone bills
that have a better shot of becoming law
i salute the president
for putting forth the legislation that
he did
there are others who want to do
piecemeal and that may be a good
approach
too as the number of illegal border
crossings continues to surge along the
southern border
today the biden administration
officially rolled out new instructions
to immigration and customs enforcement
officers
limiting who qualifies for deportation
and now ice confirms
that a limited number of ice detainees
have begun to receive the covet 19
vaccine
even as millions of americans await
their first shots
now we did not see president biden at
all today but
he did just put out a statement and it
reads in part these are not
democratic or republican priorities but
american ones i've laid out my vision
for what it'll take to reform our
immigration system
and i look forward to working with
leaders in congress to get this
done brett and fischer live on the north
lawn kristen thank you